por ciento literalmente significa por
cada 100 esta connotación con respecto a
100 también aparece en palabras como
centésima centavo centuria así que si
alguien te dice el 7 por ciento y los
tres separando a propósito para que se
ve esta connotación esto equivale a
siete por lo va a poner con número 100 y
esto escrito como fracción sería 7% con
eso en mente veamos ahora si podemos
escribir punto 601 como un porcentaje
como un porcentaje entonces queremos
escribirlo como algo sobre 100 y para
esto lo escribamos este punto 601 como
punto 601 sobre 1 vemos que este número
es exactamente lo mismo pues es el
número dividido entre 1 vamos a
multiplicar este número por
dividido entre 100 no se altera porque
sin entre 100 es igual a 1 y lo que
vamos a obtener es una fracción cuyo
denominador es igual a 100 que tenemos
aquí entonces en el denominador si
multiplicamos estos números uno por 100
nos da si en el denominador y en el
numerador que tenemos punto 601% bueno
siempre que multiplicamos por ciento por
múltiplos de 10 recordemos el punto
decimal un lugar a la derecha entonces
si multiplicamos por 10
esto es 6.0 1 y si multiplicamos por 10
nuevamente es decir multiplicamos por
100 obtenemos 60.1 entonces punto 601%
nos da 60.1 déjame escribirlo nuevamente
aquí si queremos multiplicar 0.618
multiplicó por 10 nuevamente entonces
hemos multiplicado por 100 para obtener
60.1 así es que una vez es por 10 la
siguiente vez
por 10 nuevamente es multiplicando por
100 entonces tenemos que esto es 60
punto 1 sobre 100 esto lo podemos
escribir entonces como 60.1
100 60 punto 1% lo cual también lo
podemos escribir como 80.1 por ciento y
si lo ponemos con una sola palabra sería
60.1 por ciento o usando el símbolo
conocido 60.1 por ciento hemos terminado